it is the people of the state of New
York against Donald J Trump
the case to be called here next week is
called history legal and political
there are police all around the
courthouse here ready for the circuits
the first time spectacle of a former
president booked fingerprinted and
photographed but Donald Trump won't be
handcuffed by arrangement with the
Manhattan district attorney Alina Haber
is a trump lawyer on a legal team
negotiating his surrender to the court
he's doing well this is the hoax of all
hoaxes as my client would say
um
he is this is truly in this country
election interference we're seeing
selective prosecution we're seeing a
person who's been persecuted endlessly
and that is because he is strong in the
Democrat Party I don't believe wants him
to win again there is much talk that
Donald Trump wants to make a public show
of himself at court being as he would
have a victim is that correct do you not
think he's a victim do you absolutely
never ever give up the persecution theme
was given the mini movie treatment in a
trump team video his fundraising and
Republican polling through the
victimhood is red meat for the Trump
support base even if a Democrat
president wasn't biting I'm no comment
on that I have no comment at all
the criminal pursuit of trump will have
a bearing on the direction of U.S
politics Americans are watching
extraordinary events surrounding a man
who was once their president and wants
to be again whatever his criminal
baggage he's committed a lot of crimes
and I'm glad that he's being indicted I
think they should throw him under the
jail
quite
energy at all he's not a good person
he's made a lot of mistakes I think we
all want to see the justice system do
its job as things stand the indictment
remains sealed so his contents haven't
been made public for now but it's
understood that Donald Trump faces
around 30 charges of document related
fraud he'll learn exactly what they are
when he stands before a judge in court
he's not the first prominent name to be
brought to the 15th floor of this
building in February 2020 Harvey
Weinstein the film executive appeared in
the same courtroom and was convicted of
rape and sexual assault
this Trump case relates to hush money
made to pawn star Stormy Daniels
prosecutors think the payment could have
been falsified in the Trump books and
that there could have been a campaign
fund violation this case is widely
viewed as the least of Donald Trump's
legal worries less serious charges and
more difficult to prove than other
potential prosecutions over January the
6th classified documents and attempts to
overturn an election result in Georgia
given the surrounding Firestorm it is a
legal load that will test the strength
of this country's legal and political
institutions
James Matthews Sky News in New York